Hey, everybody.
Welcome to the podcast.
It's time to turn on and tune in
because today's guest is the OG of integrative medicine.
A true pioneer of health, a legend of mind-body healing
the medical mystic himself, Dr. Andrew Weil.
A graduate of Harvard and Harvard Medical School.
Dr. Weil has spent basically the last 50 plus years
studying and evangelizing holistic wellness,
underappreciated healing modalities, medicinal plants
and the reform of medical education and practice.
Named one of the 100 most influential people in the world
by time magazine.
He's also a New York times best-selling author of 15 books.
He's the founder and director of the Andrew Weil Center
for Integrative Medicine at the University of Arizona.
As well as the founder of Matcha tea brand, Matcha Kari
and a partner in True Kitchen.
A chain of something like 35 healthy food restaurants.
This man is a gift
and this is a wonderful wide-ranging conversation
that spans his extraordinary life
and delves into many important aspects
of human and planetary health.
So please hit that subscribe button,
click that notification bell thing and enjoy.
It's a pleasure to meet you.
It's an honor.
Thanks for taking the time.
I'm excited to be here with you.
I don't even know where to begin this other than to say
you've been in this game for a long time.
You're a pioneer and icon in the integrative medicine space.
And so much of what you're about.
You were so far ahead of the curve.
Like culture is only now even just beginning to catch up
to so many other things you were talking about
in the late sixties, throughout the seventies,
when you were kind of like this iconic class
I guess in some cases you still maybe considered that.
I don't know, I hope so.
(words lost in cross talk)
You're welcomed.
(laughs)
Now in a way that it probably didn't feel that way
in the earlier stages of your career.
Well if I seize being controversial
I think I'm not doing my job.
(laughs)
(indistinct)
There is a little bit of a I'm interested in that spirit.
There's a little bit of a punk rock thing going on here.
'Cause you've been pushing the envelope right from day one
from what you were writing, in the Crimson
at Harvard and all the kind of stuff that dates back
to you being in your like late teens and early twenties.
Definitely in the first book that I wrote in 1972
"The Natural Mind".
I went back and read some parts of it
and it really predicts what's happening now
with psychedelics and the positive change
that this can bring to our society.
But for a long time, I've written
and said the same thing really for almost 50 years.
And for the early part of that time
nobody paid attention to me.
And then I got a larger and larger following
in the general public but none of my medical colleagues
paid any attention to me.
And then that changed in the early 1990s.
And now integrative medicine is becoming mainstream
and it's very gratifying to watch.
Yeah it's gotta be,
it's gotta feel like you've been vindicated.
I mean, there's still so much work to be done
So much but it feels like the culture has caught up
with me in a lot of respects.
So it must be challenging to check your ego
a little bit with that.
(laughs)
You're like screaming about this stuff forever.
Well, it seems so obvious to me
the things that I've been advocating
talking about, one of my main principles
is that the body can heal itself.
That's hardly news.
I mean, that's Hippocrates said that
in the fifth century BC.
It's just that it hasn't been much paid attention to
in modern medicine.
Yeah, well, I feel like so much of your perspective
was well-informed by all the traveling that you did
as a young person.
Seeing parts of the world that were relatively inaccessible
at the time to give you a broader perspective
on different modalities of health and healing.
I had a wonderful opportunity that came my way by chance.
When I was 17, I won a scholarship to an experimental school
that took a group of 22 students and six faculty people
around the world for a year.
And we lived with native families.
So I did this a year between high school and college
that changed my life.
And I think traveling has been so important to me
and to be in other cultures
and to see that there are other ways
of interpreting reality, incredibly valuable.
I think that's one of the problems I see in our society.
We're a big isolated country
and many people have no awareness of what's out there.
I saw some statistic a few years ago that I think it
was fewer than 40% of members of Congress had passports.
I mean, amazing.
Really?
Yeah. And George W. Bush had never been out
of the country when he became president.
I mean, how is that possible?
He was the son of a president
and he'd never been out of the country.
It does seem impossible.
Amazing, but I think there's no substitute
for getting perspectives of other societies and cultures.
I mean, the most interesting and introspective people
that I know are people that are well-traveled.
And particularly people that took the opportunity
to travel when they were young and they're kind of,
their minds were still being formed
and they weren't calcified around their world views.
And then after I finished my medical training,
I then for a number of years,
I traveled a lot in Latin America.
I lived in Latin America for a number of years
studying plants and drugs and other ways of healing
and then also in Africa and Asia.
And so that's just been very much a part of my life.
Well, I'm obsessed with Harvard in the mid sixties.
I just can't get enough of learning about
what an interesting time it was in Cambridge with
everybody from Richard Alpert to Timothy Leary of course,
Skinner who I know you spend time with him.
Was there a sense that it was special then?
Well, Harvard has always had a sense of being special.
I remember there was a novel written by a faculty wife
at Harvard called, "We Happy Few".
So there was always the sense that we were this elite.
But frankly Harvard was getting passed by
when the sixties revolution started.
That was all going on in Berkeley and the West Coast.
And it was a few years before it got to Harvard
and Harvard started to catch up with what was happening.
Did you have access to Leary and Alpert?
I did, I had become interested in psychedelics.
I'd read about them right before I entered Harvard
as a freshman in 1960.
And I asked about how I could find out about these.
And I had a psychology professor who told me
that there was these two guys
in the social relations department
who were starting to study these drugs.
So I went over and met Leary at his office
and had a conversation.
This is from about 1960, 61.
Before he really we was just getting going on studies
he was doing, he was fascinating.
He had a twinkle in his eye.
He was a kind of Irish storyteller,
very charming and he genuinely thought that these drugs
these were the most interesting things
he'd ever come across.
And he thought they had the potential
to completely change society.
And he had no sense that this was gonna stir up
any kind of opposition.
Yeah it really was a culture clash though
between the administration and these,
wild-eyed professors who were
way out on a limb with some of the ideas
they want to do explore.
Well one of the ideas that they wanted to explore
was that everything, everybody was playing games
and that there was the professor game,
and the ACA university game,
well the university didn't like hearing that kind of stuff.
So I think it was inevitable
that there would be a big clash between them.
And you then began your experimental phase
around that time as well.
Also, I had read Aldous Huxley's book,
"The Doors of Perception" about mescaline.
And by chance he was at MIT.
And that fall semester that I entered Harvard
and he gave a series of lectures on visionary experience
that were broadcasted on the Harvard radio station.
And I listened to them and I wrote him a letter
and asked him, where can I get mescaline?
And he wrote back and gave me the name of chemical company.
And anyway, eventually I was able to get mescaline
and I experimented with it myself
and with friends over the next few years.
And that was before almost anyone I knew had ever those.
Right, right, right.
Do you know, you probably know Deborah Szekely?
Sure, oh yeah, she's amazing.
She's incredible right?
I spoke at Rancho La Puerta several years ago
and I had her on the podcast.
But when I was there, I kind of dug into the history
of that place and what I was starting to learn about
Edmund her late husband.
I mean, Huxley used to go down there
and it just sounded like a wild time at that moment.
And talk about healthy aging.
I mean, she's one of the most
incredible.
She's 100 now, 99?
Yeah something like that.
Really, really impressive.
I mean, so interesting how that intersection
of experimentation with psychedelics
with kind of this emergent wellness culture,
in its infancy to look back on that and to see
kind of the fruits of that labor
and the way that culture has kind of
embraced these things now.
It's crazy.
I mean, it's taken a very long time,
but I was just saying to someone yesterday that
in the past few years I was doing a lot of traveling
and lecturing around the country and in other countries.
And no matter what the subject was
I was talking about whether it was healthy aging, nutrition
the questions I would get asked would be about psychedelics.
That's why everyone wants to talk about.
And then I saw I think it was this month
or last month Vogue had a cover story
on psilocybin mushrooms.
I mean,
That is mainstream.
(laughs)
It's crazy.
It's tricky for me.
I mean, listen, just to preface what I'm gonna say
I certainly acknowledged the tremendous amount
of science that's occurring right now
in terms of healing modalities, with respect to PTSD
and depression and all the kind of clinical applications
that we're discovering are appropriate for the substances.
But I'm always challenged with how to square that
with the fact that I'm a recovery guy
like I've been on a recovery for a long time.
And within that, the construct of that community
it's very binary thing.
Like you don't use substances.
I never used psychedelic substances.
I acknowledge these benefits that we're now seeing.
It definitely flex with my mind a little bit,
because I think did I try that
and I've got a friend who's like a long time sober guy
big book banger, all the way in.
And he went and did a
supervised siliciden experience with
I don't know, whoever the kind of experts are in this field
and it was profound for him.
It will be hard really substances that you use
in the way that people use alcohol or tobacco or cocaine,
there things that people may take as on a single occasion
and have some profound experience from.
In my sense is that psychedelics
they can show you possibilities.
They don't give you any information
on how to maintain the possibilities.
And then you have to work on other ways
to find out how to extend and maintain that.
So they're not really things that you incorporate
into your daily life.
Right, right.
Although with the microdosing
and all that kind of stuff--
(words lost in cross talk)
There's a lot of that going on.
I guess my only reticence around the conversation is that
the more it gets talked about,
the more mainstream the kind of acceptance of it is,
the more likely it is that people will be using it
in ways that they shouldn't be.
Sure, I think that's always a danger
which is too bad because I think the the potential of them
is really only realized that you mentioned certain setting
at the beginning.
If people have the right expectations
and use them in the right circumstances,
and otherwise, I think you just frittered away
that potential.
When you reflect back on those early
experiences with psychedelics
and kind of pair that with all the travel that you did.
I mean how do you think about
the impact of that on the kind of broader perspective
that you've brought to the health conversation?
First of all, I don't use these things anymore.
I mean, they were things that I used in the past
and on that book that I wrote "The Natural Mind"
Alan Watts wrote a blurb for it.
And one of the things he said was that,
"When you get the message you can hang up the telephone."
And I think that really applies to these experiences.
So there's a lot of stuff I learned from them.
I don't really feel the need to repeat those experiences.
But one thing that I saw very powerfully is that
what goes on in your mind really determines
and shapes your experience of the external world.
And I've applied that very much in my work with patients,
because I just find over and over again,
that the root causes of illness
are often in the mental, emotional sphere
and not in the physical body or they're in both.
But conventional medicine has so ignored
that non-physical part of ourselves.
And I think that's a great limitation.
I mean, I think one of the things
I appreciate about you the most is just that level
of cognizance and emphasis that you put on the mind
and your willingness to delve deep into the nature
of consciousness, and these are just anathema
in conventional medical practice.
It just doesn't compute.
One of the most interesting courses I ever took
was in medical hypnosis at Columbia University
(indistinct) for Physicians.
I learned so many fascinating things there.
And as a result of that, I made mind-body medicine
a major component of the integrative medicine curriculum
that I developed.
And I very frequently refer patients
to mind-body practitioners, whether that's hypnotherapists
or visualization practitioners or any one
of a number of other modalities
because I find these things to be incredibly effective,
cost-effective,
I mean, even fun for both practitioner and patient--
And relatively free of risk.
Yeah totally. And they are so under utilized in medicine.
And I remember once I was challenged
to a public debate by Arnold Relman
who was the editor of the New England Journal of Medicine.
And it was a very publicized event.
And I mean, I have never met a more closed minded person.
His position was all you have to do is show me the evidence.
You know, you show me the evidence, blah, blah, blah.
So anything you'd show him, he'd say,
"Oh, well that's not evidence."
And one of the questions that I asked him
I said that, "The best research area
of what I do is mind-body interactions.
There's been 30 years of studies on that.
And yet these modalities are so under utilized
what would you do to increase their use?"
And his response was,
"There is no evidence for mind-body interactions."
So, I don't know what you can do with that.
There's a profound hubris around
the scientific method.
Science is truth.
Science is fact, but that overlooks the fact that
it's a method.
It's not a fact in and of itself.
It's a means of approximating truth.
It's a way to approach or discover truth,
but it's also not the sole method and it's flawed.
And I think there's so much arrogance around.
This is the way that we do it.
And that kind of approach is very dualistic or binary
in that it's controlling for this variable or this and that.
And obviously we've made, I'm not dismissing it.
It's like this is the engine of progress of course,
but it overlooks the holistic nature
of the human body and the interplay
between all of these very sensitive systems
And science and medicine, in our part of the world
are totally dominated by materialism.
You know a philosophy that says that
the only thing that's real is that which can be seen
and touched and measured.
And that if you see a change in a physical system
the cause has to be physical,
non-physical causation of physical events, doesn't compute.
It's not allowed for.
So in hypnosis there are so many demonstrations
like you can touch a person with a finger
and you have them believe it's a piece of red hot metal
and if they're in a deep trance they get an actual blister.
I mean, that is non-physical causation of a physical event.
So if you try to get a doctor to look at that or scientists,
it's just a curious thing it doesn't have any meaning.
That kind of makes me think of your interesting ideas
around the placebo effect
and the way that we kind of think about that backwards.
Fortunately, that's one of the things that's changing now,
which makes me very happy,
but still the most common ways I hear the word placebo used
are in phrases.
Like how do you know that's not just a placebo effect
and the most interesting word there is just
or we have to rule out the placebo effect.
That's what we wanna rule in.
The placebo response is pure healing from within
mediated, by the mind unmixed up with the direct effects
of treatment which are likely to be harmful.
I think I've heard you talk about the fact that
in every kind of double blind trial.
If you look at the placebo group,
there's always a few people
that have experienced the result as if they have been
taking the medication.
All of the changes exactly.
And that's the most interesting thing--
Amazing, that any change we can produce
with a pharmacological agent can be exactly mimicked
in at least some people, some of the time,
by a mind mediated mechanism.
So fortunately the change that's happened
and this is a result
of these new brain imaging technologies
is that now you can show that certain parts of the brain
are active when people have placebo responses
and this makes it accessible and real to people.
So I think placebos are being taken much more seriously.
Because now the imaging science has caught up
and neuroscience has progressed to the point
where they can provide
an explanation that makes sense to the conventional
and community.
Exactly.
And same exactly with meditation,
or there've been a tremendous number of studies
of very long time series meditators
showing different activity,
in different brain areas as a result.
So the fact that a meditation practice
can actually physically change the brain.
I mean, that's really interesting stuff.
But within that, there's this profound,
deep appreciation for the mystical, right?
Yeah.
Which is like my favorite thing to talk about.
Oh good.
(Andrew laughs)
And I suspect that was in part informed
by all these shamans and various healing practitioners
that you've experienced over the decades
in south America and Asia, et cetera.
One of the attitudes that I just can't stand is that
when scientists believe that it's their job
to make mystery go away.
It seems to me, mystery is an essential aspect
of the universe and that you have to appreciate that
and wonder at it.
Once Terence McKenna, I once heard say that,
"The bigger you build the fire
the more you're aware of the extent of the darkness."
And I think that's true.
And,
I think that at the heart of our experience is mystery,
that stuff that we can appreciate
but we can't really understand with our mind.
So how do you get a typical doctor to develop
a broader appreciation for that?
How does that work?
I mean, that's kind of at the crux of your thing.
Well, I train doctors.
At the center I have at the University of Arizona,
this is what we do.
We're the world leaders in integrated medical education.
And we train doctors and nurse practitioners
and medical students and residents,
and our main training is a two year intensive fellowship.
We've now graduated over 2000 physicians from that
in all specialties, all ages.
And it's all the things they should've learned
in medical school but didn't, including like healing
and the fact the body can heal itself and so forth.
So the people who come are self-selected
and what's happening today is that
so many people in medicine are just burned out.
They're so disillusioned that what medicine has become.
And they know there's gotta be a different way
and so they come to us
and there's a new generation out there,
I think that gets it in a different way.
There was
a social club that I belong to at Harvard Medical School
that had a motto that I always really liked.
It was, "We dress the wound, God heals it."
And that's acknowledging that aspect of things.
I mean, on the surface, obviously you've cut your hand
or whatever, you can watch it heal.
Like there is something going on that you don't
need to really attend to the body will take care of itself.
But beyond that, we don't really appreciate
the extent to which the body is constantly doing that.
Yeah and I find in my work,
one of the things that I have to do
is try to instill greater confidence in people
about their body's ability to take care of things.
You know, most people have no awareness of that
and think they've got to run off for help
as the first thing.
And what's interesting is that these are things that have
been paramount in all kinds of modalities
dating back through history that were very dismissive
of from Ayurveda the Chinese medicine and all,
I mean now I feel like we're kind of looking
at those things with an appropriate level of reverence
and critique to figure out what works and what doesn't.
Exactly.
But these are not new ideas.
(Andrew laughs)
Yeah. Hardly.
(both laughing)
I mean, you've been in it for 50 years
but this has been going on for thousands of years.
It bugs me when I hear doctors
refer to what they're doing as traditional medicine.
To me, traditional medicine is Chinese medicine,
Native American medicine, Ayurvedic medicine,
things that are thousands of years old.
I mean, our system of medicine in its present form
is maybe a hundred years old, 120 at the most
it doesn't go back very far.
But packed into that is a certain level of arrogance.
And this idea that we're always
at the pinnacle of human understanding.
And you don't understand because we have this training
and we're gonna tell you to do,
that's starting to shift right now.
But that arrogance, that hubris becomes
a bar to having a growth mindset
or an openness to other ideas.
Very well put, and to me, the essence of science
is open-minded observation.
That's where you start.
I've been re-watching, "The Knick" did you
watch "The Knick"?
Yes I did yeah.
"The Knick" is like the greatest thing on tel
it's unbelievable how good this show is.
And for those that don't know,
it's about Clive Owen plays this surgeon in 1900.
Thackery he's full of vim and vigor and ego and arrogance.
And on some level he is a genius, but he's on the edge.
He's a fanatical cocaine addict, opium addict,
but he kind of rules the roost in "The Knick" this hospital.
And what I didn't realize until I looked
into it a little bit more deeply
is that he's based on William Stewart Halsted.
Did you know that?
I did not know that.
Who has kind of a similar trajectory having been
a cocaine addict and the guy who kind of set in motion
this residency program that is a legacy today
of residents working insane hours.
And a lot of that was dictated because the guy was like
on cocaine all the time.
And he could like work around the clock.
But I bring it up because that arrogance.
He's like, "I'm the guy who's in charge, I know all."
And when you look back on it, it's comedic because
there he's giving people turpentine and soaking their feet
in mercury and doing all kinds of crazy stuff.
That's just preposterous.
But it makes you think like a hundred years from now,
what are we gonna look back on?
What we're doing in this moment and realize
how insane it is.
I gave an invited lecture a few years ago that I called,
What We're Rethinking.
And I looked at examples in the past 50 years
of practices that now we look back on
and I can't believe we did them,
but leaving people with a question of what are we doing now
that 50 years from now look back the same way.
So some of them were one is there were floor scopes
and shoe stores when I was growing up
to check the fit of shoes.
So there was this big console
and you'd stick your feet with your new shoes onto them.
And there was a big glowing green screen
and you'd see the bones of your feet
and the game as a kid was to distract your parents
and the shoe salesman.
So you could spend as much time under there as possible.
I mean, unbelievable.
More like an x-ray?
Yeah, like an x-ray in a shoe store.
(laughs)
So another one was, this is much worse.
There was the thymus behind the breast bone
is the master gland of the immune system.
It's where immune cells go to be trained
to recognize antigens and foreign things.
And it's very active in childhood
and in adolescence and shrinks in adolescence.
When I was in medical school
nobody knew what the thymus did.
It was considered a functionless organ, a vestigial organ.
Well, first of all, that's arrogance.
You don't know what the function
of something in the body is
so you say it has no function.
And then the next step is that, that allows you then
to destroy it or take it out.
And so doctors and this was in the 1950s,
invented a disease that every child had
called phonemic hypertrophy meaning the thymus is too large
treatable by bombarding it with x-rays,
which causes it to shrink immediately.
I had a good friend who was a graduate
in my undergraduate class.
And then he went to Harvard Law School.
He was clerking for a Supreme court clerk
and he got a letter one day
from Michael Reese Hospital in Chicago,
very good hospital in Chicago
saying our records show that as a child
you were taken to our clinic
for a course of x-rays directed at your thymus.
And we're now finding that people that had this
treatment are developing thyroid cancer at unusual rates.
And they urged him to come in and get checked.
He didn't even know this had been done to him.
But I mean unbelievable that kind of arrogance.
When I think about the traditional modalities
around healthcare, one thing I'm pretty certain
we're not gonna look kindly on years from now is
the myopic perspective on lifestyle, diet, nutrition,
all of these things that are the key contributors
to the real epidemics of our time,
which are the chronic lifestyle illnesses
that are killing more people than anything else right now.
And the overmedication of everybody
the treatment of symptoms, the inability to really get
to the underlying causes and to address those
in a meaningful way.
A major component of integrative medicine
is lifestyle medicine.
And I think that puts us in a really strong position
to offer real preventive advice to people.
The total instruction I got in nutrition
in four years at Harvard Medical School was 30 minutes.
Which we're grudging--
Haven't changed much.
No it hasn't changed much.
And when nutrition is taught, it's taught as biochemistry
which is forgotten as soon as
the biochemistry exams are over.
So I think most most doctors are functionally illiterate
in nutrition unless they've made an effort
to learn it on their own, which is not so easy to do.
Well, systemically the education is not about
preventing disease or the promotion of wellbeing.
It's about the treatment of disease.
In fact, that was one of my motivations for getting out
and learning other methods was
I had learned nothing about health and healing
in my medical studies.
No, I hardly ever heard the word healing used.
And it always seemed to me the main job,
my main job was to teach people how not to get sick
in the first place.
And I hadn't learned how to do that.
So let's define integrative medicine.
Well the short definition is
it's the intelligent combination of
conventional medicine and natural and preventive medicine.
Then the selected use of alternative therapies.
But I think the fuller definition is
it's a system that really focuses
on the body's ability to heal itself.
That looks at people as whole persons
not just physical bodies
that takes all aspects of lifestyle into account
that values the practitioner-patient relationship
and makes use of all available treatments
no matter where they come from
as long as they're not gonna hurt people
and show reasonable evidence of efficacy.
And how does that differ from functional medicine?
Functional medicine, there is some overlap
between functional medicine and integrative medicine
but I think they're quite different.
I think that functional medicine is very focused
on biochemical mechanisms.
I think overly focused on that.
And some of those biochemical mechanisms
I think may not have great clinical relevance.
And then in practice, their treatment is correcting
these functional biochemical disturbances
by recommending a lot of supplements to take.
I think that functional medicine
has much less emphasis on mind-body medicine
on spirituality and medicine
on the community aspects of medicine.
So I personally think that integrative medicine
is more comprehensive more robust system.
So in the training of this next generation
of integrative medicine practitioners,
there's a lot of challenges
but not the least of which is what is the business model?
because your butting up against a conventional system
that's driven by insurance reimbursed
By profit.
Yeah exactly.
You know, as dysfunctional as our healthcare system is,
and it's very dysfunctional, it's generating rivers of money
and that money is flowing at the very few pockets.
It's the pockets of the big pharmaceutical companies
the manufacturers of medical devices, the big insurers
and the big healthcare, corporations.
And those vested interests don't want anything to change.
They're making out like bandits.
And I feel bad we train the people that come to us
in a really highly and then we turn them out in the world
where everything's stacked against them.
And all the priorities of reimbursement are backward.
We don't pay a doctor to sit with a patient
and teach a breathing exercise.
We pay a doctor to prescribe drugs,
and often when the doctor doesn't think those are necessary
or they do tests,
we don't reimburse for lifestyle counseling.
So that all has to change.
There has been some progress.
I know Dean Ornish recently got a insurance reimbursement
for some of his programs, but that's the key, right?
You've got to get insurance on board with those.
Otherwise it doesn't make financial sense
especially when a big part of this is follow-up
and outreach and accountability, where you have,
kind of other practitioners in your office
who are checking in on everybody
and making sure that they're staying on track
because you can't just say, you need to go
here's the diet you need, or here's the exercise routine
and expect people to actually follow that
unless they feel, that there's some kind of program
or emotional connection to it.
Totally, and I think the challenge is that
we have to generate data that we can take the people who pay
for healthcare to show them that it's in their interest
to pay for these.
(indistinct)
Ultimately it's, if you keep these people
from getting diabetes and becoming obese
it's gonna be a far less strain
than the insurance mechanism.
Apropos of that.
I remember seeing a few years ago
there was a week long series
in the New York times about the impact
of the type two diabetes epidemic in New York city.
And one of the articles pointed out
that for every preventive nutritional counseling session
that a diabetes center did in New York that the center lost,
I think on average something like 50 to $70.
(laughs)
For every amputation of a diabetic limb, they made 6,000.
So it's a nice alignment of incentives.
Exactly, exactly.
I mean, that's a systemic change.
It's great to train these doctors
and put them out in the world.
And I believe that anybody, maybe not all people
but most people who go to medical school
are well-intentioned they wanna help people.
Absolutely and in fact,
a lot of the people that come to us for training
say that this has really restored
why they went into medicine in the first place.
Yeah, because there's so much disillusionment.
(words lost in cross talk)
Tremendously.
And that's a huge change when I was in medical school
medicine looked like a very desirable profession.
Doctors heads great status in society.
But I think one of the great promises was that
it offered you autonomy.
You could be your own boss, no longer.
I mean, doctors can not make it in solo practice anymore.
You have to work for a corporation that tells you
how many patients you have to see an hour
that tells you what you can do and not do
in the way of recommending treatments.
That's all changed.
I can't tell you how many doctors I've met
in the past few years who say they wished
they'd gone into another (indistinct)
I would imagine they have to become pretty leveraged
with debt also for all the equipment (indistinct)
Huge problems and also just the debt from medical school,
that many of them are still trying to pay off
when they're in their forties.
It's not dissimilar from the chicken farmer
who's really working for Tyson or, you know what I mean?
And they're basically servicing debt
and they become indentured to a system
that is so rigor sort of rigid in its structure.
Yeah, true.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I want a snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already
know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools
and support very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly.
And because I want everybody to experience some version
of what I've experienced
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say is,
The Plantpower Meal Planner.
Are affordable all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership.
When you use the promo code, RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff people,
for just a dollar 70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com promo code RRHEALTH
for $10 off in annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Of all the
kind of shamanistic,
alternative healing practitioners
that you've encountered over the years.
Like how do you parse someone who's got the goods
from the charlatans?
I have a good bullshit detector.
(laughs)
And some of that was refined actually,
by going through Harvard Medical School.
I'm very glad I had that education.
It gives me a standard against which to judge stuff.
Frankly and when I was in south America,
a number of shamans that I saw were drunks.
You know they were completely nothing for me to learn from.
I would say the mentor that I most value
is the one that I learned that breathing technique from
who was an old elderly osteopathic physician,
Robert Fulford.
I met him when he was in his early eighties,
he'd come to Tucson to retire.
He used the only hands-on manipulation.
He's the best healer I've ever seen.
He placed great emphasis on the breath.
The manipulative technique he did was a very gentle
he had huge hands, was great to be worked on by him.
And people he'd do a treatment and then people would say,
"When should I come back?"
And he would say,
"You don't have to come back, you're fixed."
And he would do these things and say,
"There I made these adjustments
and now let old mother nature do her work."
And I still remarkable cures in his office,
just from these simple,
I mean he was a healer,
but he had a method that also worked.
So what do you make of that?
Like what is going on?
I think first of all, he was a charismatic healer.
There was something special about him
but he also was very talented.
He had trained himself,
he had incredible sensitivity of his hands
and what he taught, made a great deal of sense.
For example, he was incredibly effective
at ending recurrent cycles of otitis media,
ear infections in kids.
And in conventional medicine
this is treated with cycles of antibiotics.
And eventually if that they don't work
they put tubes in the ears.
He said that the root cause of the problem
was improper breathing.
And that breathing was the mechanical force
that pumped the lymphatic circulation.
And if that wasn't working properly
there was stagnant fluid buildup in the middle ear
which provided a breeding ground for bacteria.
And he said, you could wipe out the bacteria
all you wanted with antibiotics
but if you didn't change that underlying problem
the infections would come back
which is what our experiences.
He would do one treatment of manipulation.
You'd see the kid's chest expanding more fully
when he finished and they never have another ear infection.
Wow.
I mean, amazing.
And I tried for several years to get one pediatrician
in Tucson to come down to his office and watch,
and nobody would come and that's the attitude I can't stand.
I finally got one an English woman who was a pediatrician
who came and I immediately sent him patients
and she said she'd never seen anything like that.
And I made a little documentary film of him,
but he was really inspiring.
And when I was working with him he charged $35 for that.
He had no equipment.
In Tucson right?
Yeah.
After you traveled all over.
(words lost in cross talk)
Yes exactly.
That's the wizard of Oz phenomenon.
That was right in my backyard
and I'd never known it was there to begin with.
It's interesting how we try to wrap our heads
around things that we don't understand and our resistance
to these outside ideas and how it takes time.
Like now we have I'm sure you're familiar with Wim Hof
and all this stuff that he's doing with breath.
And for some reason, perhaps in part due to his charisma
and the fact that he's sharing so much on social media
there seems to be a conversation around breath
and--
This is great.
The autonomic nervous system.
And what I kind of gather from everything that he does
all of which is rooted in pranayama and like ancient,
yoga breathing techniques
is this idea that we have more control over these systems
that we just believe are running automatically within us
that we can actually manipulate them.
And breadth, I think is the key to that
because it's the only function you can do completely
consciously or completely unconsciously.
And the theory of breath work in Pranayama is that
by using your conscious system
to impose rhythms on the breath,
you gradually induce those rhythms
in the involuntary system.
And thereby you get to the autonomic nervous system
and can change its function.
That's such a simple idea.
And that's something that's been paid so little attention to
in the west so it's great to see this coming.
And now it's like being studied and stuff.
And the cold exposure is what gets all the attention
but it's really the breath.
I think it's really the breath.
I mean, I think the cold stuff is great.
I have partly as a result of meeting him
and listening to that,
I spent summers in, in British Columbia, on an island.
The ocean is pretty cold there.
And I go in every day and I've gotten to like that night
I like cold dips and cold baths. I think that's good.
That's cold.
Yeah that's cold.
But I think as you say, absolutely the breath is the key
and it's wonderful suddenly to see interest in this,
there's books that have started to come out on breath
suddenly being taken somewhat seriously.
It was so ignored--
It was James Nestor's book.
James Nestor's book which is good.
What about the stories that you hear about
Sadhu and caves in the Himalayas who are breatharians
and haven't eaten food for decades.
(words lost in cross talk)
You ever met any of those guys?
No, I'm an open minded skeptic--
Yeah I wanna know where's the line?
Okay so for me, I'm willing to believe anything
but then I got to see evidence for it.
But that's different from being a closed minded skeptic,
which is what, a lot of people I meet in medicine are
they have a mindset, not the belief from the beginning.
No, I've never met a breatharian.
And there was one famous guy in Los Angeles
who had a big following,
and was caught on videotape stuffing himself
with candy bars in his seven 11.
So I don't know that I haven't seen, however
I've seen enough stuff that make me,
I'm willing to believe, Wim Hoff,
his methods where he got a lot of that
from Tibetan practice.
And those people that,
can warm themselves to an incredible degree in dry blankets
sitting out a lot of frozen shore of a frozen lake.
I mean sure.
I've seen that I've done firewalking myself
and very impressed with that.
I did it the wrong way several times.
And then I did it the right way
did one with Tony Robbins
when he was trying to set a world record
for the longest fire walk was 40 feet
over a very hot bed of coals.
And I had on a much shorter, cooler walk.
I burned my feet, but when I did that one
I was in the right state of mind
and there was no sensation of heat, I walked slowly.
I could dig my feet into the hot coals.
I had nothing, I got really high, amazing.
I mean and that was totally aware where my mind was
at the time.
Yeah and he's taken thousands of people
through that successfully.
So, how do you explain that?
All right, this is just guess.
And then it's also based on some
of my psychedelic experiences.
I think if the mind gets out of the way,
it can leave the nervous system free
to allow the body to interact with external things
in ways that it's very precise and balanced.
For example, I wanted the experience I had repeatedly
is in a psychedelic state,
walking barefoot over sharp stones,
which I normally couldn't do because it hurt too much,
but not only did it not hurt,
there were no dents in my foot.
So that's the interesting aspect, what's going on there.
And it feels to me as if, if my mind is not interfering
that the muscles on the surface of the foot can push back
very precisely to neutralize the force at the surface
of the skin.
And that's like some ability that we have,
which we normally don't see
because our mind is somehow not letting that happen.
You have this other story about doing yoga
and being unable to do reverse crow or whatever it was.
(laughs)
And then dropping acid or siliciden
or whatever that was and being able to do it.
Right. But then when it wore off, I couldn't do it again.
But, having seen that I could do it.
I was motivated to practice until I was able to do it.
It's getting the mind out
of habit--
Out of the way.
And quieting the mind.
And then it becomes a conversation around
how do you do that without exogenous substances.
I think obviously it's possible,
with Tony Robbins and that firewalk
I wasn't taking anything.
It was the group energy that he created
that caused the change.
Yeah but it's impossible
to not develop a deeper appreciation
for just how powerful the mind is.
And then it becomes even more inexcusable in my perspective,
from the lack of appreciation for that.
And in medical and in the mental health space
where we're just over-medicating people like crazy,
especially kids, the extent to which
they're prescribing SSRI
The vast experiments--
being done with kids.
We use drugs for ADHD and everything like that.
We have no idea what these do to the developing brain.
And it's ironic that the word psychiatry comes from Greek
it means soul doctoring, what a great concept.
But it's ironic that of all the medical specialties
psychiatry is the one that's become most
mired in materialism.
The dogma is that all disordered thinking and emotion
is the result of disordered brain biochemistry.
And the only way to deal with that
is by giving pharmaceuticals to change that.
And if that were right, if that were true,
we would be much more effective
at dealing with mental illness.
They don't seem to work very well.
No. That's a very good observation.
If you look at a psychiatry journals
and look at the ads for the pharmaceuticals,
you would think that depression, anxiety,
that these would be things of the past, and it's not so.
They are not very effective these methods.
I also think that there's something going on culturally,
where we've been lulled into this belief
that we should never be anything but happy.
I mean you wrote a whole book about this.
(laughs)
Like, if I'm not feeling good today
the first impulse is to
find out how to medicate it.
I don't have enough
seratonin in my brain so I better take something.
I think that's a great mistake.
We're not supposed to be happy all the time.
So beyond breath, what are other practices?
I'm sure there are
certain things--
It's all the things
you know, it's like physical activity
is one of the most powerful ways of stabilizing mood.
Nutrition has an enormous effect on brain function mood.
I think who you associate with the moods are contagious.
You know, if you spend time in the company
of people who are depressed and anxious,
you're more likely to be depressed and anxious.
I mean, there's actual research showing that
if you have a happy friend
who lives within a half mile of you,
you are more likely to be happy
and the effect falls off with distance.
You can actually measure this.
I mean that's something I tell people to do.
But only people have never think about that.
Well, a big piece of that is this loss of community
that I think is endemic to modern culture.
And especially acute right now during the pandemic.
Of course, I'm sure are you friends with Dan Buettner?
Yeah.
You know, Dan?
Dan's coming over here tomorrow.
Oh great tell him hi.
But you know, one of the many things I appreciate
about his work is that he understands
that you can't shoulder the individual
with trying to solve all these problems on their own.
We have to re-imagine how we construct communities
to make these things just in the background.
So that they're the easy choices.
Whether it's bike lanes or access to healthy food or,
neighborhoods organized, so that community is inevitable.
Very good point, and I think--
And that's part and parcel of the integrative medicine
message, right?
Yes.
Like those two worlds should merge with each other
in some way.
We place a great deal of emphasis on community
and the importance of community to healing and health.
Absolutely.
Another thing that most strike you as kind of amazing is
the kind of recent appreciation for mushrooms.
(Andrew laughs)
Non-psychoactive mushrooms.
It's like everyone's drinking mushroom coffee
and we're all talking about healthy mushrooms.
And this is something that
you've been talking about forever.
I was fascinated from mushrooms from an early age
I think partly because my mother was very afraid of them.
And she told me when mushrooms came up on our lawn
that I shouldn't even touch them
because they either got poisoned.
And somehow that made me wanna know about them.
They seem strange and interesting.
And actually throughout history
I think people have found mushrooms strange.
No, that it's unclear.
They didn't grow from roots like plants.
And they would suddenly appear from one day to the next,
their strange colors and odors and tastes,
and some of them are utterly delicious
and there's some that can kill you.
And now we found all of these
that have interesting medicinal effects.
They're really unusual, interesting life forms.
And as you may have heard we are more closely related
to mushrooms than we're to plants.
Yeah, that's a mindblower.
And the extent to which the underground invisible network
is a communication network that basically plays
this massive role in the entire eco system.
Exactly, I mean, I remember learning this must've been
in the seventies or eighties, and I had no idea this
that trees in the forest could not live
unless they form symbiotic associations with mushrooms.
That the rootlets of trees actually become sheathed
with the mycelium of mushrooms.
And if you take tree seedlings
and sterilize the roots and plant them
the trees are completely stunted and don't grow normally.
I mean, I had studied biology at Harvard
I never heard of that,
it's a completely new idea.
Yeah that's wild.
And now Paul Stamets is the guy
that everyone wants to talk to about this,
but you're the guy who introduced him to this whole thing,
which is crazy.
I read that in Michael Pollan's book.
I got him interested especially in medicinal mushrooms.
'Cause he was only interested in the magic ones
when I met him when he was a young guy.
So of all the mushrooms, like what are the ones that
you feel like we should be incorporating into our routine?
Oh gosh, I think it's probably best to incorporate
several, a number of different species at the same time
because they seem to work synergistically.
I think reishi, which has good anti-inflammatory effect.
Maitake mushrooms, oyster mushroom, shiitake.
A lot of these are the ones that have immune modulating
effects that increase our resistance to infection
and cancer, very useful.
Lion's mane, which is now being cultivated.
Why it's a very good edible mushroom.
But this has a unique nerve growth factor.
Appears to improve cognitive function,
may help ward off dementia.
I think that's a really good one to learn about.
Chaga which is one another one of these
shelf fungi that grow in trees.
And how about cordyceps?
Is that --
That's my favorite.
Okay I thought it could be.
I mean, it works as an endurance booster
in terms of how it helps you sort of maximize oxygen uptake.
Like it's very effective.
So this is a strange one, it's a parasitic--
(words lost in cross talk)
Yes it's pretty gross.
It's a fungus that grows on the back of a caterpillar.
Caterpillar right.
At very high altitudes.
Yeah and that kills the caterpillar
and then sends up this fruiting stock.
Although in practice now it's cultivated on grain.
But this has a long history of use in
traditional Chinese medicine for people who are debilitated,
either from injury or illness
or old age of increasing energy.
And there's been good studies showing increases
aerobic capacity.
So that's a good tasting mushroom.
And now it's a good one to know about.
The more you learn about this
you realize just how mystical and magical--
(words lost in cross talk)
It's insane.
I love mystical and magical.
Good to keep that in mind.
That's your thing now right?
Where does the interest in matcha come in?
Is that when you traveled to Japan?
I went to Japan first, when I was 17.
Part of that when I was in that
round the world student exchange program.
And I lived with Japanese families.
First one was outside of Tokyo.
This was 1959 when Japan was a very different place.
And the family I live with,
there were supposed to be a student there
that's that was studying English
but we had no language in common.
But the second night I was there, the mother of the family
indicated she wanted to take me next door to her neighbor
who was a practitioner of tea ceremony.
And so the three of us sat around
and this woman made matcha.
And first of all,
I was blown away by the color of matcha.
I'd never seen that vibrant green was just amazing.
And then also the bamboo whisk
that's used to whisk matcha in a bowl.
It's just a marvel of Japanese craftsmanship.
I was fascinated with.
So in the 1970s, I was going to Japan fairly regularly.
And whenever I'd go, I'd bring Matcha back
and turn people onto it.
Nobody that I knew had ever experienced
or knew anything about it.
And somewhere I think it was in the 19, late 1980s, 1990s,
I tried to sell matcha through my website.
I imported it.
I found a company that I could get it from in Japan
but it was way ahead of its time.
So people weren't ready for it.
And then, I was amazed to see matcha becoming popular.
Just one of the many things--
Just one of the many things
I was way ahead of.
(words lost in cross talk)
However, I very disappointed that
the matcha that I saw here was really inferior
because matcha it's such a fine powder
that it oxidizes really quickly.
And when it oxidizes, it loses that bright green color.
It becomes bitter.
It's not pleasant.
And most of what I saw available here was that way.
So I was determined to see
if I could make really good matcha available.
So I found that a company that managed to get
the URL matcha.com which is a big score.
Yeah that is.
And made a connection with a traditional
matcha producer in Japan.
And we import and sell
I think some of the best matcha you can get.
And by the way we can offer your listeners a discount.
Oh cool.
So it's matcha.com, the company is Matcha Kari.
And if they use the discount code rich 15.
All right.
They will get a discount--
(words lost in cross talk)
I think that's very generous thank you.
But matcha, it's the only form of tea
that in which you consume the whole leaf
and it's got a higher content of antioxidants
and flavor compounds and other helpful compounds.
And some of this is because
of the unusual way that the leaves are grown
in the last three weeks before harvest,
they're grown under a very heavy shade cloth,
90% shade cloth and then response to that absence of light
the leaves grow bigger
and thinner and produce more chlorophyll
which is why it's so bright green
and more L-theanine which is the calming compound
that moderates the caffeine
and antioxidants and other good things.
So I think for all those reasons matcha
is one of the most helpful forms of tea out there.
I love it.
It does give you a little bit of a boost,
but it's kind of a calm energy.
Exactly.
And sustains itself for a little bit longer.
Very different from coffee.
And the color is magical.
It's magical. I love it.
It tastes great.
But I know well, the difference between a fine matcha
and what you typically see, it's a much darker color.
Darker or yellowish.
Yeah, you can tell it's been oxidized.
And I see this with a lot of these,
quote unquote superfood products,
the more money there is to be made
with the lack of kind of quality control or regulation
in this space,
whether it's Moringa or, whatever it is,
Camu camu, whatever you're trying to get.
It's really hard to know
like what's the good stuff and what's--
(indistinct)
Yeah and if you've had
no experience of the good stuff, you don't know.
Right and you don't know how it's harvested,
how it's grown, how it's picked,
how it's stored, how it's shipped,
all of those things play into
whether or not it's maintaining the qualities
that you're purchasing it for.
And most of these products are not good for that reason.
Exactly.
By the way, I get a little disillusioned
with all the talk about superfoods
because we have plenty of superfoods right here,
like berries are superfoods
and you can get very good quality organic
berries that are just loaded with antioxidants
and anticancer compounds.
Now that those are superfoods.
Going all the way back to the botany days.
(Andrew laughs)
Yeah exactly.
How many people were in the botany department.
It was an attic of the university, you know, first of all,
it was the botanical museum.
You're studying what?
Biology was being completely taken over by
molecular biology and gene stuff at that point.
And botany was a little annex
that was considered so antiquated.
And it was in the botanical museum
which was above the glass flowers in the--
In the Gregor Mendel wing or something.
Exactly right.
But my professor
Dick Schultes was the father of modern ethnobotany.
And that was just a wonderful association
that I formed with him.
And having that background in botany
has been invaluable to me.
I know very few physicians who studied botany
and it was a shock to me when I went to medical school
to see that the people teaching me pharmacology
generally had no firsthand knowledge
of the plants that these drugs came from.
And to see how different the whole plants were
from the chemicals isolated from them.
So that's given me a great perspective.
Well, I mean, no surprise given that
the idea that nutrition in and of itself really had no value
in terms of how the organism operates.
So, but that's changing.
I love all the new sciences coming out about the microbiome.
That's fantastic.
That is such a revolution.
That's as fascinating as that mushroom kingdom.
Absolutely.
And is mysterious I think.
Yeah, when I was in medical school,
the teaching was that yes there were these organisms
in the colon and they helped with digestion,
but that was it.
And that people who took
acidophilus or ate yogurt were health not so.
Boy has that changed.
Yeah. It's changed a lot.
Well, I'm a long time plant-based vegan person.
I know you're not vegan,
but somebody who appreciates the plant kingdom,
perhaps as much as anybody.
So I love talking about plants.
Can I just say also I love talking about plants.
I love plants. I garden a lot.
I have lots of plants around me all the time,
but one of the reasons that I would love to see
people move in the direction of eating more plants
and reduce consumption of animals.
This is a very concrete thing that we could do
to deal with one of the factors that's driving these
zoonotic diseases that are responsible for this pandemic
and which are putting us at great risk for future pandemics
of very serious diseases.
It's that we are encouraging organisms to jump
from animals to people because of climate change,
deforestation, that our methods of agriculture
and you look at the ones,
what are we gonna do something about
one of them very concretely is it to
reduce our dependence on animals for food.
And if there was just less of that, that would put us
ahead of the game.
Yeah, a hundred percent
in the way that we need to appreciate the human body
and its ability to heal and self regulate.
We need to own that perspective
with respect to the planet, right?
For sure.
And if we're,
clearing rainforests
and creating algal blooms in our waterways
we're devastating ecosystems,
and we're creating less and less
areas for these species to exist
in the manner in which, they're meant to exist.
And so they end up encroaching on other areas
and these species are coming into contact
that perhaps wouldn't otherwise,
and all of this creates this toxic situation
that leads to zoonotic disease and the decay of the planet
and a very simple, practical
and effective thing that we can all do as individuals
is reduce that meat intake.
You still like the fish though.
I still like fish.
I became a lacto-vegetarian in 1970.
And I ate that way for about 15 years.
And then I was going to Japan frequently.
It is very difficult to go to Japan and not eat fish
because fish is in everything.
And then I was reading about health benefits of fish.
So I started eating fish.
And since then I've been a pesce, pescatarian.
But you're not going to Japan right now.
That's correct.
(laughs)
Come on, I know Sylvia Earle was all over you.
She was all over me.
She begged me to tell people not to eat fish.
Did you watch, "Seaspiracy" on Netflix?
Yeah.
She's great in that movie.
She's great.
It's a big problem where there aren't
gonna be fish in the ocean.
From the way we've over harvested them.
I'm gonna convert you back to being vegan.
All right you can work on it.
How do you feel about lab grown meat
or lab grown (indistinct)?
I think It's interesting,
I mean look we can have a discussion
on the margins about the health implications of that
but I think we need to focus on the elephant in the room
which is the extent to which our dependence
on industrialized animal agriculture is wreaking havoc
on the planet.
We are a meat obsessed world, and that has to change
if we wanna preserve our ecosystems.
This is one tool in a tool kit for accomplishing that.
I agree.
And I would say probably, I would tell people
in this country, the place to start is with beef
because I think that's the one
that has the worst consequences.
Yeah there's also issues of antibiotic resistance
it's a toxic stew of so many problems that we could redress
if we just reduce that dependency on it.
So whether you go a hundred percent plant-based
or 90% plant-based, or you start,
just making some simple changes
in your diet on a daily basis,
like these these things are important to do
and to take seriously I think.
So you still like a little cheese though, right?
(Andrew laughs)
You know what I did?
My wife is a plant-based cheese wizard
and she started this company called SriMu
she's really like come up with the next evolution of cheese.
So I brought you some samples I'll share
with you afterwards.
I would love to try that.
I will be very interested to do that.
I'm also very interested in a new micro protein foods
that are being developed from cultivating fungi
and mushrooms.
Yeah. There's this weird intersection
of the science catching up with
like sort of hard science catching up with food science
to create interesting products
out of everything from algae to mushrooms
and all this kind of thing.
Are your kids vegan?
They are, but they're now at the age where
they need to have their own exploration.
So we give them a wide leash.
I mean, they stray from the hardcore vegan path,
but they've never had meat, so they'll have,
but they'll like, you know, my teenage daughter
she wants to have a beyond burger,
or stuff like that, you know.
She wants to have some junk food, you know, it's okay.
It's like, I'm less interested in that than I am in,
where her or all of my kids' diet
is gonna be five, 10 years from now.
And we've just tried to instill in them,
a certain level of education.
So it's less about like the day to day
and more about like in general, kind of where they fall.
But it's tricky with people with food.
I know.
You know, you've been doing this for a long time.
Trying to get people to change their habits.
I mean, come on. Is there anything harder than that?
How do you approach that when?
Well I usually tell people not to try to do
make global change, but to do it in small pieces
like start by, I mean, the most important thing
is to start by not eating refined,
processed and manufactured food.
That's the main step that I would urge.
I mean, if we could just do that,
imagine how different
(words lost in cross talk)
the world would be.
And another one is we're
in such a nutritional mess in this country.
It's hard to know where to start
but the other place I'd start is to get people
to not drink sweet liquids.
It's not just sodas, it's fruit juice
and energy drinks and putting sugar in coffee and tea
and all that.
That would be a big step.
And we've got to do something about
these farm subsidies I think.
Again, it goes back to a misalignment of incentives.
Absolutely. Everything is as backward.
We've made the unhealthiest food cheapest and most available
and people eat what's cheap and what's available.
Extending that thought in thinking about
the disastrous state of healthcare.
If you had your druthers,
like how would you address health care reform?
Well, first of all, we don't have a healthcare system
in this country.
We have a disease management system
that's functioning very imperfectly
and getting worse by the minute.
We have to have universal healthcare.
It's unconscionable that the richest nation
on earth can't guarantee basic healthcare
to all of its citizens.
You're socialist.
Yeah. Well, there you go.
I think there should be a universal income to.
Then I think we have to really break the hold
of those vested interests on the system.
I really see, we have to get away from dependence
on expensive technology for managing conditions
in terms of shifting the whole enterprise away from
disease management to health promotion.
The problem is you run up again against those
vested interests again.
It's whether one example is the subs form subsidies.
There's last I looked something like 46% of US hospitals
had fast food restaurants in their premises.
And if you try to change that,
this brings money to the hospital.
It's like almost everywhere you look,
it's like, you're up against that kind of stuff.
Well, and in the way that the human body
and the planet are holistic organisms
politics as a whole like,
you can't talk about healthcare reform
without talking about election reform
and campaign finance reform, because it's the lobbying,
industrial complex
(words lost in cross talk)
There has to be
a grassroots social political movement
in which we start electing different
kinds of representatives who weren't beholden
to those vested interests.
I don't see that happening.
Who do you think is getting it right?
Like overseas, Finland,
like these other countries.
You know I think
Germany and Australia do better.
They both have two tiered systems where there's
a government insurance and there's also private insurance.
They seem to work somewhat better.
But you know, most of the countries,
you look at the UK, Japan
that had very well-functioning national health systems.
They're broken down for the same reasons.
It's an aging population,
the epidemics of lifestyle related diseases,
dependence on expensive technology.
We're I think farther over the cliff than others.
I don't see anybody that's got it right.
When you look at culture right now with the internet,
it's all about subscription services
whether it's Netflix or the New York times,
and I've often thought like healthcare should be,
like I would subscribe to a service
that was some hybrid of being able to visit
practitioners in person and do digital,
online stuff
That's an interesting idea.
Where I could get my blood work done.
Interesting.
I could consult about diet and nutrition
and all those things.
Interesting idea.
And ultimately if develop like,
oh every week we check in or something like that.
The insurance company covering that,
it seems like a leap but they're not gonna then
have to pay for dialysis or
(words lost in cross talk)
Well, that's what I mean,
you got to show them that it's in their interests,
that you're gonna save them money by this.
But it's so radical
compared to the way that we're doing it now and--
But we're gonna be forced to change
because this is unsustainable the way it's going.
Are you optimistic about that?
(Andrew laughs)
I think the system's gonna crash.
We're spending something like 18%
of our gross domestic product on healthcare
and we have worst health outcomes
than any other developed nation.
It's indefensible in so many ways.
How do you think about, ancillary to that,
like the opiate crisis and--
Well I think that's a great opportunity
for integrative medicine.
Because, it's very clear that chronic pain
can not be managed by opioids alone
as standalone treatments
and that treatment has to be integrated.
So I just see that as an opportunity that's forcing people
to look at other ways of managing conditions.
Of all the alternative modalities that you've come across
hypnosis, meditation, breath work, yoga, all the like.
What do you think are the most kind of under appreciated?
Well as I told you, I'm a big fan of osteopathic
manipulative treatment.
I think that's great.
It's unfortunate that only a small percentage
of osteopaths today do manipulation as a primary therapy.
And I hope that'll come back
because it's a brilliant technique.
As I said, I'm a huge enthusiast for mind body interventions
and the whole range of them I think are terrific.
I have long tried to create and boost the field
of nutritional medicine.
And when I write treatment plans for patients
almost always the first item or a couple of items
were about dietary change
and making dietary change of primary therapy
before you even think about other things to do.
Are there supplements that you recommend
that you think are appropriate?
I think probably everybody should
take a good multi nutrient,
a supplement that has basic minerals and antioxidants.
And I think a great public health intervention
will be to provide a multi nutrient supplement
free to school kids.
That's a good idea.
That seems like a no-brainer.
And the prison inmates, I think that would do a lot.
Simple.
So, and beyond that,
I think it's probably a good idea for people to take
vitamin D and check their vitamin D levels.
I think most people are vitamin D deficient.
We just live in doors.
Even in Southern Arizona where I live,
because dermatologists have made people so paranoid
of the sun.
Afraid of the sun.
Well also, it's not just a matter of going outside.
It depends on where you live.
Like pretty far south in this time of the year
for getting vitamin D.
It's like, the line is through Atlanta.
So if you live north of Atlanta for half the year
the sun has a too low on angle for you to make vitamin D.
So, yeah, I think that would be important.
How do you think about all of this
in the context of the pandemic and COVID?
Well I think the clear principle is that
the healthy organisms are resistant.
So the healthier you are,
the less likely that you are to contract that
or the less likely to get severely ill.
How dare you?
We're not, we're not allowed to talk about that.
(Andrew laughs)
That's is dangerous
But you know, I also have to say
I think we were so miserably unprepared
in this country for this.
And I hope it's a wake up call
because we're certain to be facing,
other and probably worse things like this.
And I hope we get our act together next time.
Yeah, I hope so. I hope so.
I mean, listen,
it's all the things that we've been told to do
are appropriate from social distancing
to mask and all of that.
It's all fine, but it is frustrating
that there is no conversation about
taking personal responsibility for your health
and the idea that we should just be locked down
and completely isolated and told to stay in doors,
that doesn't square with what we understand
about what we need to do to optimize immune function
of our bodies.
True. Well, I hope that's gonna change.
(laughs)
Final thing I wanted to ask you is
if in some parallel universe
you got called up to be surgeon general,
what would be top of mind to put in place
in terms of regulations or policy?
I would really work on nutrition.
I mean, I think that's such a crying need.
Remember when Michelle Obama tried to do that though?
She got crucified.
I know. But I think that it's gotta be done.
I mean, whether it's like putting
a syntax on sugary beverages,
doing something about fast food restaurants in hospitals
this agricultural subsidies,
all that stuff I think is like
those are critical things that have to change.
It's crazy that there's still fast food restaurants
in hospital.
Unbelievable.
And how difficult it is to eradicate them.
I'll tell you one quick story.
I got a letter a few weeks ago from a first year
medical student at university of Pennsylvania
who tried, started to campaign
to get the McDonald's out of the university hospital.
He got a petition going among the students.
They got publicity in the Philadelphia papers
and he was called in by the Dean of students, who told him
if he persisted in this, he jeopardizes his medical degree.
I mean in a nut shell that's the problem.
There's something very, very wrong with our system.
That, that would be the case.
It's terrible, terrible.
The hospital they'd signed a deal with the devil
and that was it.
I know. So this is what we're containing with.
So we need you to stick around for another 50 years.
I'll do my best.
You're a gift.
I'm so grateful for the work that you've done over the years
and what you stand for.
And it is cool to see culture catching up to you.
And it's an honor and a pleasure to talk to you
(indistinct)
Thank you for having me.
If people wanna connect with you?
Well, my website is dr.weil.com, D-R-W-E-I-L.com.
The website of my center at the University of Arizona is
integrativemedicine.arizona.edu.
And that has a find a practitioner link
where you can find graduates of our program
who are in all states and all specialties.
Matcha.com is the website of Matcha Kari.
Rich 15.
Code, rich 15.
Use that and get your discount and--
And True Food Kitchen.
I love True Food Kitchen.
Good. We've got 37 of them now.
And I think we'll open more and that's been very gratifying
to me because basically that's how I eat
and it's been good to see other people like--
Yeah, it's great, it's very tailored
to whenever you're--
And there is something for everyone.
I go in there as a vegan.
I never have any problems at all.
I've been to the one in Santa Monica
and I've been to ones when I'm on the road--
(words lost in cross talk)
I'd like to see,
I'm constantly pushing for more vegan options there.
So, I'm doing what I can.
I think you could do
(indistinct)
Tell me about it.
(laughs)
And sometimes they're on the menu,
but not enough people order it or whatever
sometimes it's not available so--
But if you ask,
I mean when they had their full menu, they'll make anything.
Yeah. They've done that for me.
They've done that for me.
And I think it's cool that, I mean 30, how many 35?
37.
37 of these
to create a successful, I mean, it's not a chain
like a fast food chain,
but is it a franchise?
It's not a franchise no.
But there's that many that are doing that well
with kind of offering super healthy food.
Even in Texas and Kansas city
and it's great to see that happen.
How many more are you looking to open?
We'll see once things normalize, we'll keep doing it.
That's cool.
That's good to have a robust commercial enterprise.
That's been fine.
Offering healthy items for people. Good for you.
All right. Thanks man.
We'll come back and talk to me again soon
I'll appreciate it.
Okay, I'd love to.
All right appreciated.
Peace, plants.
Plants, yes.
Yes.